hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
this is probably the biggest content
dump that I am obviously going to be
spilling on you guys this season and
probably any other future season that
this game has I don't think I've seen
this much content release on the exact
same day and then stuff coming in the
future in a very very long time we have
a new event which old players will
definitely remember what this is three
whole sets of weapons armor
customization a unmasked hero and maybe
a beautiful Roman rework as well either
way we got a lot of stuff to talk about
in today's video so without wasting any
time I like the view if you do enjoy a
subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you're gonna be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on enough
they definitely stay subscribe to the
channel and with that let's get started
with today's video so to start off this
new season is called a year for season
two tyranny it starts on June 11th which
is this upcoming Thursday of course if
you're watching this the day this comes
out in the background you're going to be
seeing the trailer for the story of the
season and to add to this according to
one of the game writers and I quote
apollyon was supposed to be killed at
the end of the game ankle I don't know
what that means I don't know if she's
actually alive or if they were just if
she's actually dead this is some person
reenacting it either way they said that
they would explain in due time what that
means but it's obvious that they need to
point this out as she is very apparent
within the trailer some other info is
that they are switching things up a bit
there is it going to be a huge content
dump on June 11th with the start of the
season it's actually going to be split
on June 11th we're going to be getting a
Centurion rework hero balance new
customization a new battle pass and a
new events on August 6th is the new hero
combat update and more that combat
update referring to the testing grounds
one that we had a while back so the new
hero isn't going to be releasing on the
same day as the season and it's roughly
about eight weeks if my math is correct
so roughly around the ending of campaign
four or the beginning of campaign five
it seems I wonder how this is going to
be playing out as we've never really had
anything like this so I'll be curious to
see how this is going to work
and for just for information sake we are
going to be talking about the stuff
releasing on the 11th so the sentry work
the hero balancing the customization the
battle past the event that's we're gonna
be talking about in today's video cuz
that's all the information that they
shared with us first up is the Centurion
rubric first up his zone is now faint
able and targets swappable very similar
to what we had in the testing ground so
for all three hits you can go
back-to-back between different players
to spread that damage or if you don't
want to you can always feint it his
charged heavy finisher is now faint
scible unlike live game where there's
not really huge potential with this to
play around with the opponent now you
could do a whole lot of that for the jab
it is now feint able just like in the
tester gun as I stated before the jab
can feint GB and can catch rolls stun
was removed from the uncharged version
as do not piss off a lot of players it
is still on the charged version and can
also be target swapped and fully charged
has uninterruptible stance just like
ward and shoulder bash later in the hits
they kind of wanted to even a few things
out with this sort of move the second
and third light for Centurion is now 500
milliseconds which they used to be 600
and 700 milliseconds respectively so now
you might be seeing a lot of second and
third lights actually landing with
Centurion now for the quick throw that's
completely gone from his kits but this
was now replaced with a lot of mix-ups
with jab for parry counter though it
also branches into jab allowing you to
max jab off of walls as you're seeing so
pretty much what you could do parry that
move
Max's jab right into the wall wall splat
heavy charged me Oh Eagle Talon huge
combo going off that what you're seeing
also is a whole combo as well with a lot
of the throws from jab it's going to be
at like two or three lights than a jab
two more lights than a jab you know this
is pretty much a big combo obviously you
have to take into consideration that you
don't run out of stamina and they don't
parry it but assuming they don't parry
and they don't block this there's a lot
of big damage coming up for this combo
next up is legions kick and now that's
500ms and eagles fury is now 800 m/s his
forward strafe is now a lot larger and
more forward dodge distance you're gonna
be seeing this weird video of sent and
soon that kind of walking you're gonna
be noticing that sent as X
be running into soon da and could
potentially outpace him meaning scent is
actually a lot faster now in guard so
you definitely want to be up in these
people's faces even more than you were
before there's also an increased
movement distance on his zone attack the
light opener the heavy opener the heavy
finisher jab and eagles fury so lots of
increased movement once against who
really solidified this being up in the
person's face for a good majority of the
fight
the devs also brought it up towards the
end but the cutscene is now gone due to
updates with the jab which is fantastic
news but quick tease that's not all for
him and you'll see why in just a little
bit later in the video on top of this
being a huge rework there's also going
to be some regular Shiro bouncing for
the general cast as well for yeoman
Gunder uninterruptible stance on the top
heavy opener is now 600 the side heavy
opener is 500 so a little bit later in
the move and serpent smite is now 700 so
a little earlier in the move you're
gonna be seeing uninterruptible stance
changed a lot for a couple of the
characters up and coming so keep that in
mind and for the very last thing for
your arm is that his stamina damage and
regen pausing of stamina on his melee
attacks has been reduced so a pretty big
part of his kit has been reduced but I
think it's totally fair also for the
finishers light plus melee finisher is
now frame disadvantage meaning if you
fight aayiram that constantly does light
melee light melee you actually can out
beat the Urim most of the time using
your own light attack so you can stop
him from constantly punishing you so
even if you get hit or if he happens to
with the hit no matter what the
situation calls for if you do get male
aid try to throw on a light yet probably
you're gonna out beat him and then you
won't be stuck in the corner so much
with him for heat so carry
uninterruptible stance on the uncharged
heavy opener is now gone meaning there's
no heavy on red anymore for the sweep it
is now 1,000 milliseconds for the
uninterruptible stance and then also
light finishers aren't enhanced anymore
so if you block the attack it stops the
combo and if you happen to miss the
first light but you know go into the
light finisher it is a lot easier to
dodge that now so it's a huge weight
lifted off of your shoulders as if
you're fighting heat so kiri now but
that's not all as her fourth feat which
is that large word
still can't pronounce is now considered
a top unblockable attack meaning you can
now parry her forth feet next up is Shu
goki same interruptible thing as well
with him having 304 light openers and
his heavy openers now being 433 so a
little bit later in each of the moves
there's also going to be small very
small health changes to some of the
characters JJ getting a small health
debuff meaning now he has 140 health as
opposed to 145 and la bringer na has 140
health as well as opposed to 150 the
very last thing that has to do with
balancing is Nisha her deadly duet fee
is now 20% more damage and her infection
got a major buff it has now light hit
reaction it is 10 seconds long and does
10 damage per tick with a possibility of
getting 10 ticks of potential damage the
cooldown is now 2 minutes as opposed to
3 minutes and the radius was just
slightly smaller by about one meter
lastly is BP and now sadly he can only
bulwark attacks now no more feats no
more players entering ladders no more
rag dolls only attacks very sad to hear
it's a very small change all because you
normally don't see the stuff too often
but a change nonetheless next up is now
customization and scent has been
unmasked I can't believe I just [ __ ]
said that in a video of course this
means he gets a whole new set of gear
and I'm not just talking one set or two
sets I'm talking like four or five
different sets of helmets with him
unmasked it is incredible the amount of
armor he got for this you can decide
whether or not of course if you want to
keep this new face or keep the mask it's
totally up to you this theme of the
armor and even the season is now a lot
darker than normal so some edgy err
armor will be present and for who is
getting gear at the very moment it is
now the main 12 cast and sent as I did
not see any armor in the video for the
DLC one character so besides sent all
the DLC ones might have to wait once
again some of this armor is really
creepy looking you know Conqueror Mordor
and are even moving to Nobu she's well a
lot of these different armors are crazy
stuff I would say the Knights look
really nice but I gotta give it to the
Vikings this time for not getting [ __ ]
armor in my opinion and
I'm more happy about that than anything
at the moment the Vikings had a huge
improvement just this year in terms of
Arbor so it's good to see that they're
getting some love that they deserve the
woollen also got some nice-looking gear
the Shaolin monkey mask is a bit
questionable at some points but you know
there's a lot of new updates with some
of this new armor especially for the
wool and specifically as they have one
of the more vibrant and looking armors
in my opinion it's a little interesting
I have to admit Lucia also got some good
looking armor as well as usual and JJ
now has a mask so if you want to put a
mask on JJ you can totally do that
these are lootable meaning this is just
normal regular armor that we normally
get right you play a game you get armor
at the end of the game same spiel
[Music]
you
but now there's also a set of weapons
that we can loot at the end of the game
just like back in the day before year 4
when we had a battle past there is now a
full set of armor and a full set of
weapons you can get at the end of the
game some of these may not fit into your
style of course as there's a very
specific yellow silver in green texture
to them but I still think that there is
some potential for them especially the
shield heroes as there's a lot going on
with those shields let me know if this
is some cool color scheme that you like
for the season or if you wanted more
edgy colors but if you're thinking about
edgy colors just give it a couple
minutes we'll talk about
you
next what you are seeing is the main
stuff for the Battle pass the mood
effects you see is the [ __ ] cows and
they seem to be like a new group
invading the game possibly the stuff on
the trailer according to the developers
this video you're seeing right now is
more of a tease whereas right now you're
seeing a lot of the weapons in the
battle path so now here's the second
weapon set of that we're going to be
getting this is from the battle pass
meaning this is paid content so if you
don't want to do the paid content
there's no worries as you're going to be
getting a full set of weapons from
previous and we also still have one more
to talk about in the future but for
these like I said this is going to be
the battle pass weapon set and these are
going to be paid so you have to get the
premium version of the pass and right
off the gate I gotta say BP holds you
know holds the top spot for the
best-looking piece of weaponry I've seen
in this entire set that is fantastically
looking there seems to be a trend of
some Sun and Moon appearing in the
weapons and shield so there was
definitely a theme going on here and I'm
a huge fan of that shikko key coming in
from left field with a super bright blue
weapon same as heat so kiri personally I
think I'm a big fan of the Past weapons
we are seeing now as opposed to the
season 4 lootable weapons they're both
really good sets of weapons but if I had
to choose it definitely be the past
weapons at the moment I also noticed a
lot of vibrant colors are normally don't
see on weapons like this dark brights
yeah dark and bright blues a pink for
raider and tons of other colors like a
whites i'm seeing four characters i
normally don't see and they also said
that these weapons are somewhat
noticeable on the battlefield so that's
a good or bad thing depending on the
situation you might be in and remember
that these are battle past weapons and
if it's anything to go off the last
battle pass you roughly have to get
around tier 96 or so as the last 4 to 5
tiers is usually saved for executions
which they haven't showed us so roughly
tier 96 at least from last season was
the highest they had for weapons so this
is probably the highest you'll have to
go to get every single piece of weaponry
from the battle past weapons assuming
you are going to get the premium version
you
and then lastly for the Khan
dump is the new event coming immediately
into the season metal trials and if that
name rings any bells you're right this
is pretty much test your mettle with a
twist on the honor games so it's got the
tester metal gameplay with the crowd and
camaraderie of the honor games there's
going to be two chapters involved here
it's either going to be a mix of people
every time you queue up so you might
have to fight apollyon and her Knights
chosen and the samurai or Goodman dart
and the Vikings just like we did years
ago but in Chapter two it's gonna be
chosen shadow chosen apollyon and
Goodman dart as the team every single
time you queue up for people that are
unaware what this beautiful beautiful
event is it is a 4v4 elimination AI game
were you in three other buddies have to
four before the bosses of this story
every round gets harder as the enemies
gain health buff shield buffs damage
buff the more you win so make sure
you're on your a-game cuz this [ __ ] gets
really hard really quickly this would be
taking place in the shard of all maps
with lots of festivities everywhere and
a lot of vibrant reds being here
obviously it wouldn't be an honor games
Eska vent if the iconic band was back
which is easily some of the best news
I've heard all season and the minions
are everywhere like I'm talking there's
a dude chillin up on a drawbridge
there's so many people chillin even
outside of the map there's so many
different tents it's a very packed party
of people here next up is the main menu
for the season and if you can tell
there's a nice little bonfire by the
player which is kind of illuminating
their face of it with some lights and of
course on the main menu and then there's
the face off screen as well apparently
the main menu and the face off screen
may randomly change one day they never
stated when although I might take pics
that maybe Jun has something to do with
that with the new hero but maybe I'm
wrong also the old gear is back in terms
of outfits embossing z' and emotes so if
you didn't play awhile back and you
wanted to get those for sure definitely
grab those highly recommend the ion war
emote one of the best spams still to
this day and but that's not all
we have two other things to talk about
for this event there is also going to be
new armor you should be expecting from
the past
so older heroes it seems like our going
to be getting possibly older different
versions of the same gear or it's going
to be just the original gear from years
ago they never stated this so just make
sure if you're gonna be playing the
events with you know one of the older
characters that was present during that
event make sure to let me know on that
either if it's the exact same gear as
last time or it's slight variations but
a good majority of the cast we have now
haven't been in this event so they're
gonna be getting whole new different
sets of armor and these look fantastic
there's so much white facepaint going on
black face paint lots of different black
colors it is really really sick and I'm
so glad that this event is back cuz I
completely forgot how good some of the
color schemes are but that isn't the
last thing we still have to talk about
the third weapon set coming to the game
and that is this event weapon set
there's gonna be a lot of black and gold
colors coming in and I'm just gonna let
the video play as I kind of do the outro
and kind of segue into that it's a lot
coming in the very first day of the game
not only do we have the season 14 armor
coming the season 14 weapons we have the
new event metal trials armor and the
metal trials weapons and then also the
battle pass weapons as well that is
about five things I listed in terms of
whole content that you can get on the
very first day of playing the game
that's not even to mention the hero
coming later in the game with the combat
update and a bunch of other things
coming and if you're a set player this
season is for you you got so much armor
I'm actually a bit jealous cuz gladiator
didn't get anything sadly but you know
maybe next season and yeah that's going
to be the end of this extremely long
video sorry if this is a bit too much
for you I just there's so much
information to unpack like I said we
talked about the Centurion rework we
talked about hero balance we talked
about three different types of weapons
two different types of armors coming the
events the battle paths all of this
stuff releasing in just a couple days on
June 11th with eventually a future video
going live of it being on August 6th or
roughly about August 6th talking about
the new hero the testing grounds combat
update and they only said of course and
more which could just mean an entirely
new event more weapons tons of ideas
coming but yeah with that guys that
going to be the end of the video today
very very long video let me know what
you guys think about the video down in
the comments below also let me know what
you guys think about the new season you
gonna be playing sent the sentry were
cooled the armor look cool let me know
all thoughts that you guys think about
the stuff in the comments down below and
that take care guys have a greatest Jew
day peace out and good bye
[Music]
[Music]